[Music]  it's Kardashian catch-up time I just  wanted to take a picture right now yes  Kim Kardashian's hubby Kanye West popped  up at Trump Tower Tuesday morning for a  mystery meeting with president-elect  Donald Trump who would only tell  reporters that they spoke about quote  life a source tells EG kanye is  currently in NYC to look for a new  studio space for his fashion line oh you  got me a car meanwhile Kanye's  brother-in-law Rob Kardashian got a  major surprise from fiancee blac Chyna a  range rover and Kourtney Kardashian and  Kylie Jenner are at war Kourtney we  challenge you in your house to out horse  over elf on the shelf so the sky is out  number one he's hanging upside down  finally kendall jenner shared this new  snap from her latest vogue spread  opposing with Tyler the Creator who of  course frequently collaborates with  Kendall's possible boyfriend ASAP Rocky  hey beautiful girl you already know we  keep it rolling on the side  [Music]